votre sujet avant d'échanger avec le
premier invité de cette édition autour
de la gare de la verrière je vous
propose de découvrir cette affiche c'est
celle d'un film l'inconnu du lac est
récompensé par le prix de la mise en
scène de la sélection un certain regard
au dernier festival de cannes cette
affiche a fait l'objet d'une
interdiction à saint cloud à versailles
les maires des deux communes ont demandé
à l'entreprise de côte de retirer tous
les supports publicitaires du long
métrage
la ville de versailles n'a pas répondu à
nos demandes de précisions mais sur les
réseaux sociaux les réactions se sont
multipliées notamment l'association mots
festi qui appellent à manifester devant
la mairie es2 es5 loup demain mercredi à
19h15 au mot festi qui a twitté tout au
long de la journée pour appeler à
manifester un autre tweet également
celui de mathieu colombani c'est le
délégué général du parti
chrétien-démocrate conseiller municipal
à montigny qui soutient le retrait de
cette affiche et souhaite un retrait
aussi dans les autres communes voici
l'un de ces tweets
cette affiche est pour lui une preuve de
l'acculturation en marche en france en
d'autres termes la mise en route d'un
processus par lequel un groupe ou un
individu assimile une culture différente
qui lui est étrangère voilà mathieu
colombani qui contestent donc cette
affiche qui demandent son retrait et
puis je vous rappelle aussi que la
première unions gays dans les yvelines
c'était à poissy hier à dans la plus
stricte intimité nous aurons l'occasion
de faire réagir à ce sujet karl olive
demain le conseiller général ump des
yvelines qui est candidat au poste de
maire dans cette commune de poissy il
sera l'invité du 7 8 des 18 heures